[Music]
my name's Brad I'm the product lead for
Google endpoint management I'm part of
the cloud identity product so part of
the cloud identity team I'm gonna try to
keep it high energy and keep you awake
here for a little bit I'm gonna try not
to talk too much we have some demos that
we're gonna show you so I'm gonna bring
up some of my colleagues that are listed
here in a little bit but first I want to
set a little context before before we
get into those demos so so talk a little
bit about cloud identity in general so
the idea here is that with the
proliferation of mobile devices and the
movement of enterprise access to the
cloud its kind of changed the way that
employees work all of us expect the same
kind of consumer grade access from our
enterprise applications and and it's
it's actually putting a burden on IT to
support this right so the workplace is
undergoing a transformation to support
this expectation IT decision makers are
at the forefront of creating a secure
connected and collaborative work place
where identity access and device
management is front and center of all of
that so you know network security was
different when I started my career and
so was collaboration and I think those
two are kind of tied hand-in-hand
together as long as we stayed on the the
network we stayed secure this tied us to
our desks and it hindered the way we
could work with with others and so in a
way that the IT security model kind of
dictated the way that we could work with
our partners and our vendors and our
customers and so now that that perimeter
is gone and we've got this dynamic
security posture tied to users and
devices and applications the result is a
better way to work that allows us to
easily collaborate across different
applications from different places on
different devices Google pioneered this
concept we call it beyond Corp in a 2011
we've been working on this for you know
eight years now the intent has been to
enable every employee to work from
untrusted networks without the use of a
traditional VPN and we've been
perfecting this internally for these
eight years shifting all of our access
from the network to individual users and
devices allowing them to work from
anywhere and so what we've done is we've
taken that and we packaged it up and
we've started selling that as part of
our cloud identity product now the cloud
identity product was officially launched
in March of last year so it's about a
year old but it's not actually a new
product it's something that that we had
baked in as part of the G suite for
years but we finally thought oh this is
something that even if you're not making
the move to the productivity suite we
think our customers could benefit from
so that's kind of the overview of cloud
identity so what does device management
have to do that with that that's that's
what I'm here to talk about in more
depth so first let me talk a little bit
about what I think device management is
or endpoint management so a Primmer
right
so I think of it in three pillars so I
think of device management itself where
you're locking down a device so that's
you get an inventory of every device
that accesses your data you enforce
policies on that device before they're
allowed access so you might enforce a
passcode on a device you want to be have
the ability to take action on that
device if something happens if the data
becomes a if the device becomes lost or
stolen
so basically locking down a device
before you allow access to sensitive
information the second pillar is
application management so once you've
got a device and it's locked down in a
way that you feel like it's secure you
want to make sure that your users are
productive on that and so you want to
make sure that they have access to the
right applications and they're
configured in the right way and so
things like application whitelisting
applications that separate out work and
personal data distributing applications
and configuring them that sort of thing
that's the second pillar of what I
consider enterprise endpoint management
and then the third piece is general
administration of your fleet of devices
so you've got these devices out there
you want to audit and report on them you
want to be able to maintain a threat
mitigation protocol and that and just
general Enterprise management of your
device fleet so why is all of this
important so more than one quarter of
smartphone owners do not use a screen
lock so this is a you know couple years
old here when you dig it
that data that's not limited to
consumers right so that means that a
quarter of all folks carrying a modern
smartphone have figured out how to turn
off screen lock on their device I don't
know if you've set up a smartphone
recently it's hard to do so you you've
made the decision that I want to you
know I don't want to be bothered with a
device lock on my device and I just want
it to be open for the world to get into
so and then depending on the the data
that you look at only about one in ten
or maybe 15 percent of devices used for
business use are under device management
if they're not under device management
then you don't know if you have enforced
a screen lock on that device or not so
this is what I'm here to say all right
if you're an administrator and you're
allowing enterprise access to your data
on a mobile device and you don't have
device management turned on on that
device then your employees can leave
their device at a Starbucks and it could
potentially be completely open somebody
can pick up that device and they can get
complete access to whatever sensitive
data resides in that device not only is
that bad for the potential loss of your
data it also could you could run afoul
of you know security regulations as well
so I think that is bad and so I'm on a
mission to try to fix that so why why do
I think that is so the reality is it's
it's been difficult to set up device
management there's you you send people
through a lot of Hoops there are a lot
of privacy concerns to set it up and so
in general people don't want to deal
with the headaches of implementing
device management and so at Google where
we're on a mission to try to fix that
we're on a mission to try to figure out
how to make device management as easy as
possible as seamless as possible
so that as an administrator you don't
have a problem turning it on and as an
end user you don't have a problem having
device management on your device so our
mission is to maximize user productivity
while keeping data secure these two
things are
diametrically opposed to each other
right so it's really easy to keep your
data secure you lock it down you don't
give anybody access done right it's
really easy to keep people productive
they can get access to your data anytime
anywhere you just open it wide wide for
access anywhere but then it's not secure
so we're constantly looking at what is
the right balance between those two
things I think we've we've we've
achieved a pretty good balance between
those two at Google our endpoint
management we manage more than 55
million 30-day active devices
that's includes Chrome OS Android and
iOS and some other devices we've managed
to grow pretty rapidly over the last few
years and we've done that by making
simple easy to use device management and
that's those are the demos that I'm
going to show you a little bit later I
want to show you how we've done that we
it in many places we've turned on device
management by default so that we've got
basically even for administrators who
don't know they need device management
we've got their back so I'm going to
talk a little bit more in three areas
around device management and I'm gonna
give a demo in each one of these areas
so hopefully we'll be ready to go on
these so first let's talk about
comprehensive protection so from on the
mobile side we manage a OS and Android
we manage company owned devices we
manage personal devices we also help
secure the desktop through the use of an
endpoint verification Chrome extension
that's something that we launched last
year and talked about it next last year
we curated install G suite apps we're
going to talk a little bit more about
that and show a demo a little bit later
and we also are big fans of Android
enterprise and we are support Android
work profiles to allow selected edit
control where you can completely
separate out your work and your personal
data on a device so that you don't bleed
between the two
today we are launching a new feature
it's a drive file stream management so
if you're not familiar with drive file
stream it's the world's largest hard
drive so drive file stream allows you to
link up your cloud drive to your your
windows or your Mac machine it looks
just like a regular hard drive on your
device it automatically syncs in the
background the files that you need the
first thing that you hear from
administrators is we love this feature
but we want to make sure that we have
control over that if the device becomes
lost or stolen we want to make sure that
we can take care of that device so today
we are launching management of that
device we can limit drive file stream
access to only company owned devices and
should that device become lost or stolen
we can wipe that device and/or block
that device and to show you thanks and
to show you I'll show you a demo of that
today I'm going to pass it over to my
colleague Sachin Sachin cool hi everyone
my name is Sachin we will have two
personas today one is device
administrator with the cap and one the
CEO of the company the company name is
techne PSICOM we deliver pizzas at
lightning speed so I'm in admin console
admin dot goggle comm in Apps G suite
drive and doc settings I'm inside drive
file stream I have a loud drive file
stream in my organization with this as
Brad told admin we'll be able to
inventory all the devices which are
accessing drive files offline I will
also be able to block and wipe the
devices I have also the capability to
allow dry file stream only on authorized
devices like company on devices but
today
we'll give a demo without enabling the
same so let's switch the persona and I'm
here I'm the CEO of the company tech
nice calm we deliver pieces at lightning
speed so I have a plight and I want to
work offline so just now I have
installed
Ryu filestream in my organization in my
this laptop so let's login for the first
type first time from this machine such
in P technician calm let me let me put
my magic password and as you can see the
very files have started to load up so
let me open drive file folder and as you
can see how these like presentation
which I need to give it to my investors
the presentation so let make let me make
some of these files available offline so
I have a demo as well let me make it
offline so that I can do some updates
over here so I'm going on the flight and
let's go back to the domain
administrator let me wear my cap cool so
just now my CEO called me and said that
he has lost his Mac machine on the
airport so and he's CEO so he has a lot
of confidential information let me go
and see if they there exist a device
boom we have a bunt device with such in
name let me go deep dive into the
machine so as you can see I can see the
serial number of the machine operating
system of the OS which is Mac this is
the Mac machine how much is the cache
size I just now download it like 100
more than 100 MB what is the drive file
stream version what he when it was the
first synced when it was last synced on
the left side I can take actions like
block the device so that whatever data
is present it will be removed from that
device and no further access will be
allowed from that device I can wipe the
count for one time so that one time data
is removed from the device I can delete
the device or I can view the audit
information of the device so that what's
happening on the device is feasible very
easily so as you can see
let me block the device you can see it
on right side what happens so let me
block it and when device is blocked boom
all the data from the device is gone
administrator has blocked this device
from this computer so that I can no
longer access it and the device data is
gone as Brad mentioned we are launching
this today
thank you search and go back to the
slides I love that sweet sweet when a
demo pulls off like that great
so next one let's talk about easy
management then we'll come back up for
another quick demo here so I talked a
little bit about our growth and device
management so so one of the things that
we've been focused on is what is the end
user experience for device management
you know I think that a lot of people
hesitate to turn on management because
people have to jump through too many
hoops you know they don't want a ton of
calls there their Help Center on how to
set up and get access to Gmail and drive
and calendar and that sort of thing so
what we implemented was agentless basic
management for all of our G suite and
cloud identity customers what that gets
them is an inventory of all the devices
that access their accounts it allows
them to enforce a pass code on those
devices and it allows them to
selectively wipe the accounts on those
devices and it's important to note that
it allows them to wipe the accounts on
the devices but not the devices of
themselves so it means that the
administrator has control over the
corporate data on the device but they're
not going to be able to wipe somebody's
baby pictures off of that device we've
turned that that we can do this without
installing an agent on the device just
the act of say logging into Gmail
enables this device management we turn
this on by default for all of our new
chief suite customers about a year ago
and we've been slowly rectal retro
actively applying it to all of our
existing G suite customers we haven't
finished that rollout yet but we're in
the process of doing that so it's a very
easy way to get management of every
single device every single mobile device
that touches
Touches G sweet and cloud identity
accounts we're really pleased with this
because what this means is even the
administrators who haven't figured out
yet that device management is very
important to them the first time that
someone leaves their mobile device
that's filled with you know health care
data or social security numbers in a in
a Starbucks unprotected we've got their
back they can go and they can wipe the
account off that device so very pleased
with that
for those for those enterprises that
need more bells and whistles and more
policy enforcement we do provide more
advanced controls in that case it's not
agent list you'll have to install a
device policy controller on the device
but we do work very hard to make that as
easy as possible and so you know what I
like to say is that you know you're all
here today at Google cloud next to talk
to us about enterprise software you may
be aware that Google also has some
consumer brands that we work on as well
so so what we do is we take some of the
lessons that we've learned from
providing great consumer experiences to
billions of users and we try to apply
that to enterprise software as well and
so even in the places where we might
require our end-users to jump through a
few extra hoops to get more advanced
management on their devices we really
focus on the end user experience and try
to make that as seamless as possible so
that so that the administrator doesn't
get burdened with a lot of support calls
and the end user knows exactly what is
happening on that device we're
completely transparent about the rights
at the administrator has on that device
and ultimately they end up installing
and getting on their way and being
productive and whatever they need to do
with that with that enterprise
information and then finally we also
spend some time thinking about how do we
make the admins life easier and so one
of the things we've implemented are
customizable rules on the admin side so
that you cannot and so you can implement
or automate everyday tasks on the
administrator size so things like oh I
you know I want to lock down a device if
someone tries to log in with the
passcode you know incorrectly five times
in a row I might automatically trigger
an account wipe on that device to
protect data on that device so today I
want to show you we've we actually
launched this a couple of months ago but
we've extended the agentless management
concept on Android to include
application management so in addition to
inventory in the device being able to
enforce a passcode on the device and
being able to wipe the account on the
device we also on Android can whitelist
applications and push those applications
to Android devices without the need to
install a device policy controller on
the device and so once again we're gonna
have sach and show us a demo of that let
me switch to the demo please can we
switch to the demo please yeah that's
right excuse me can we switch over to
the computer please there we go Thanks
cool hi again my name is Sachin and
again I have two personas one with
administrator with cap and one CEO
without cap so I'm in admin console
admin dot google.com
I'm admin of techne at comm we deliver
pizzas at lightning speed I'm in device
management setup and what you can see is
device management is enabled by I and it
is enabled in the basic mode as Brad
mentioned admin will be able to enforce
screen lock on the device will be able
to remove account from the device and we
will be able to do application
management so let me go to the
application management inside admin
console device management app management
and Here I am in the Android app
management you can restrict app
availability to white listed apps only
but to do that you need advanced device
management which is of course part of G
suite itself but today I am going to
talk about mainly basic device
management you can do whitelist
applications as well as make
applications installed silently in the
background so let me manage these
applications so for now I have white
listed around 13 apps
so let me go to the lookout app and make
it make it install automatically let me
edit the configuration and as you can
see I can automatically install app on
all these devices so rest of the
settings will be applicable for the
advanced device management so let me
switch the persona and go back to my
device cool hi everyone I am CEO of the
company last time I lost my laptop so I
am logging in from my mobile phone so
here you can see there is only one
account which is my personal account let
me add my corporate account which is
techniques are calm so let me add it as
you can see I have very secret password
on the device
let me put such a in P at tecna's accom
let me put my magic password let me
agree to the terms of conditions and as
you can see all of my information which
I need to talk about like the
presentation and so on the marks the app
and all the information is present for
so that I can talk to the investors let
me go to the Play Store and let me find
out what all apps are recommended by my
administrator as you can see in
background automatically look out app
has started to download because I had
done that setting in background so let
me go to tech Nizar calm and as you can
see there is home this is the new tab
which were added which is work apps so
all the recommended apps which are done
by administrator are visible this is
without device policy app or controller
being on the device let me switch the
persona let me go to the administrator
what happened oh we are a power up here
snag these monitors are out - yeah yeah
there we go
all right temporary glitch so lit so
just now again Sachin called me back and
the CEO called me back and again he lost
his mobile device as well so as you can
see why I go to device management
devices and I see one device here let me
wipe the account from the device so all
the account related data confidential
data goes away from that device so let
me pull this screen so that you can see
on right side also what happens so let
me wipe the account and it's account is
wiping boom the account is gone so you
can see it from even Gmail app there is
no account there's no technical comm
account and even in Play Store it is
gone what we also have done latest is we
are showing one notification to the end
users so that they can uninstall all the
apps which are installed or associated
with that particular account so let me
click on this and as you can see there
is a lookout I have Salesforce app these
apps I had installed it where the
techniques are calm I can go and delete
it and then with this deletion all the
data associated with those apps is also
going away so we are making it safe and
secure
thanks thanks Bret Thank You Sachin so
it's easy agentless management you know
we were really happy with this and
that's something we did in conjunction
with the Android team all right let's
talk about enterprise ready and this
one's a little bit more in depth and
we've got a exciting demo we want to
show you on this one as well and then
we're gonna eventually get into some
questions if you have some questions you
can submit them on the dory which is
linked in the description on the next
step or we're gonna have some mics up
here so stick around for that so let's
uh we're
the homestretch here so on the
enterprise side so we've talked about
easy management we're very focused on
that
that's not to say that we don't want to
support the enterprise use case we are
Enterprise ready for those folks who
want bulletproof management we were here
for you
so we do provide all the bells and
whistles you would expect advanced audit
capabilities to get reports about users
and devices and OS versions we showed a
little bit of the easy app management we
provide more advanced app management for
our for both iOS and Android when you
want to install a device policy
controller that includes on Android the
ability to create manage configurations
that you can push out to your devices as
well we provide proactive security
recommendations for device management
with our Security Center integration and
just recently Android Enterprise
launched the Android enterprise
recommended program for EMM s this was
in this past January and we were one of
the launch partners for that one of the
features that we're talking about is
it's not quite launched yet but it's
coming soon so I mentioned earlier we're
fans of Android Enterprise and the
Android work profile the ability to
completely separate out work and
personal data on and the Android phone I
say that not just because we're Google
and Android is Google although maybe but
also because they've really thought
through the enterprise use case and it's
really easy as an EMM for us to kind of
flip a switch and separate out work and
personal data on a device it's not quite
as easy to do that on iOS but we
recognize that a lot of our customers
have a need to provide enterprise
support on iOS and so one of the
features that we will be launching soon
and we have in testing now is the data
exploitation protection for iOS which
does things like restrict copy/paste
between corporate and personal accounts
on on an iOS device so watch for more
announcements to come on this in the
coming months throughout the year I want
to talk a little bit about something you
should hear a lot about throughout this
conference context aware access so
Kennett traditional mobile management
and traditional device management has in
the past been a very binary thing or
which is you put a device policy
controller and advise it makes sure that
policies are enforced on that device and
it's either compliance or not compliant
and then you allow access and that model
is not going to continue to work because
there are many different signals that
you need to look at on a device to
determine whether you should allow
access and those signals change over
time because they change depending on
the user that's logged into the device
they change depending on the
applications that are being used on the
device they change depending on the
environmental variables like what
network the device is on what country
the device is located on etc in context
of where access is something that we are
working on to support those types of
security scenarios there's more to come
in other sessions and I'm gonna have a
slide here that it will show you some of
the sessions you should go watch to see
about that so what we are launching in
beta is the ability to take that this
beyond Corp devices API will allow us to
integrate with third parties to ingest
additional signals from other companies
to supplement that context of where
access rules engine so what we look at
is we work with partners partners send
us data on oh here are the types of apps
that we see installed on the device that
might be malicious or other things other
environmental variables and we put those
into our rules engine an administrator
can make a decision on whether they want
to grant access to corporate data on
those devices or not and so what we want
to do is rather than tell you about it
we wanted to bring up a partner to talk
about it so
Sneha from lookout is going to come up
and tell you a little bit about
integration that we've built with
lookout for this thanks for having me
Brad so hi everyone my name is Sneha
Sadananda I'm a senior product manager
at lookout so I want to give you some
context as we all know today employees
are working from everywhere we are
working from coffee shops Airport
movie theaters and we are always
accessing a corporate data like email
our Docs
slides etc on mobile devices so that
poses a pretty big challenges for
enterprises who have completely embraced
mobile devices throughout their
workplace so how can they ensure that
corporate data which is being accessed
from these devices are actually
happening in a secure fashion and also
at the same time they have to balance
the user privacy as well as not disrupt
the user experience so today here I'm
here to talk about how we're going to do
that with Lookout in Google flower-like
jannetty next slide so for those of you
have not heard about Lookout
so we are lookout mobile endpoint
security we help enterprises protect
corporate data by preventing any kind of
threats that can happen on employee
mobile devices we have been doing this
over a decade and we have protected over
more than hundred million devices in
across 150 countries and for enterprises
we actually protect across a spectrum of
risks and on a broad range we divide
them into four categories so the first
category that we have there is called
app based risks so an example of this
can be a malware or that can be either
downloaded from play store or even side
loaded on an employee device an example
of a zero-day malware that lookout
detected is a Pegasus iOS spyware some
of you may have heard of that one and we
have device based risk so this one is an
example of this can be when a device
could get like routed or or jailbroken
yeah at least shortly going to show you
a demo of that and then we have network
based risk where you could connect to an
unsafe Wi-Fi there could be a
man-in-the-middle attack is an example
of that
and finally phishing attack can happen
when an employee could click on an email
or malicious email which could be either
as a text message or even on a social
media platform like whatsapp so what we
do is when anytime there is a risk
detected on any of these four categories
we provide protection for corporate data
through
we call it as continuous conditional
access next slide so for this
integration with lookout and Google
Cloud identity what we have done is we
have integrated our device health data
with the beyond carp devices API so when
an end user is trying to access a
corporate resource like let's say G
sweet on their mobile device in
real-time we will give context about the
health of the device so once they use
our use we get to know what the context
of the device is then you can apply all
of these rules engines as well as you
can apply different enforcement policy
as an admin to make sure that only safe
devices get access to the corporate or
resources so without giving too much
away I would like to invite Ethel till
she bagua from Google who will actually
show a demo of this integration hi
everyone thanks Anna so I'm going to
show you a demo today of the devices API
and how a third party like lookout can
use the devices API to enforce greater
security on devices that are managed by
Google so here I have a device on which
there is no device oh yes so here I have
a device that there is no agent on this
device this is just a simple device on
which I have my personal account I'm
calling myself Harry Potter and I'm
going to add my work account here and
I've just started a new job at this
company called tarragon and I'm logging
into the device I'm adding my corporate
account now which is Harry Potter at
tarragon da TV and once we log in I need
to enter my password of course so this
is my password and oh did I actually
show it to everyone sorry I'm here I'm
in I I see my work email here and my
boss has just sent me this new document
okay well I thought there was an
interesting email in my personal account
but before I go there I'm told to
activate the lookout application so I'm
gonna activate it here so activate enter
my work email address and what Licata is
now doing is it's basically scanning my
device I need to give it the permission
so that it can do its job
you know it's scanning my device it's
making sure that everything is okay with
my device and it's analyzing things now
in the meantime I can show you on the
Google admin console that the device has
been registered and approved without an
agent and on the look-out console here
you'll be able to see that the device is
connected and secured and so if you go
back to the device screen you see that
you know look out found note of no
issues here so what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to go to my personal email
and oh there's a application for the
university I was wondering do I apply to
so I'm going to click on this link so
that I get that application and it's
giving me some language that I don't
really understand so I'm just gonna
click on that link and it's gonna
download this file I don't know what
that file is but it looks like if I
download it I get into the university so
I'm gonna do that and you know behold
this is Lookout basically getting
triggered and saying that the device is
now you know this file is harmful and I
should not basically do anything with it
I'm going to close it but just because
the the file was downloaded on this
device now you will see that in the
Gmail client the workaround has been
eliminated so if I had downloaded any
files or anything all those will be gone
and how this happened actually is
because on the Google admin console the
administrator had configured a rule now
this is under under Google admin you see
a rules tab and
within that there is a rule here that if
a partner signals you know that there is
a high risk on the device then you
should wipe the corporate account from
that device and so if the basic
integrity says that there's a high risk
we should wipe the corporate account on
that device and and that's the rule and
if you look at the audit logs you will
see that the latest audit logs will show
this is at 120 p.m. that the risk was
changed from none to high and then the
account wipe was pending and then
executed so this happened without the
user actually having to do anything and
this shows how we can collaborate with
other partners thank you
great thank you okay
homestretch one thing I wanted to
mention we were named a 2018 Gartner
appear insights customers choice for
enterprise mobility management suites
that was probably about nine months ago
I'm particularly proud of this we're not
in the Gartner Magic Quadrant at the
moment but our customers went and
nominated us for this award they said
things like we like Google EMM because
it's simple and easy to use and those
are the things that we're trying to do
so that makes me very happy
hopefully you take away one thing from
this talk I think device management is
very important I'm pretty biased about
that because I'm the product lead for
device management at Google but I think
if you if you're allowing access to your
enterprise data out in the wild you
really need to make sure that you've
locked that down in some way so you can
get device management anywhere it
doesn't have to be with us what I want
to make sure you know is it doesn't have
to be difficult so if you already are a
G suite user if you're already are g
suite customer if you're already a cloud
identity customer you can get it from us
at no extra charge so you know you don't
have to get it from us but get it
somewhere that's that's what I'm trying
to say so if you'd like to learn more
about what we're doing you can go
cloud.google.com / identity and if
you're interested specifically in the
beyond corp api is that we showed if
you're interested in being a partner or
if you're interested in beta testing as
a customer send us an email at beyond
Corp Alliance dot Alliance at google.com
and we'll put you in the queue for the
sign up list make sure everybody has
time to take a picture of that before I
switch to the next slide one other thing
I want to show you get your camera's
ready for this
we've got sessions here throughout the
week this is one of the first sessions
here are some other sessions that I
think you might be interested in the
partner sessions of the ones marked PA
are are limited to partner track only so
if you're if you got to pee on your tag
you can go but I would I would encourage
you to go and check some of these out
we've got a lot of exciting things
coming
[Music]